صعدت الجامعه العربيه ضغوطها على نظام
الاسد لحمله على وقف حملته العسكريه ضد
حنس والمدن الثائره عليه وطالب وزراء
الخارجيه في ختام اجتماعا بالقاهره طالبوا
مجلس الامن دعم نشر قوه عربيه امميه في
سوريا اضافه لجمله اجراءات تصعيديه
اخرى
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين هل تملك خطه التحرك العربيه
الجديده فرصه حقيقيه للنجاح في حل الازمه
السوريه وكيف يمكن تجاوز العقب الروسيه
الصينيه اذا ما عرضت الخطه على مجلس
الامن انهى وزراء الخارجيه العرب يوم
اليوم مارونا بجمله ق قرارات عدها البعض
تقدما كبيرا على صعيد العرب العمل العربي
المشترك ففضلا عن خطه نشر قوات مشتركه في
سوريا طالب الوزراء باحكام العزله
الدبلوماسيه على نظام دمشق في كل المحافل
الدوليه وتشديد العقوبات الاقتصاديه عليه
اما بعثه المراقبين فقد اصبحت من الماضي
فيما تستعد تونس لاستضافه اجتماع نهايه
الشهر لتدشين ما بات يعرف بمجموعه اصدقاء
سوريا ثلاثه اجتماعات والهم واحد سوريا لم
ترفع الدبلوماسيه العربيه اذا رايه
الاستسلام لا بل ان تصعيد النظام السوري
حمله قمعه للمطالبين برحيله املت واجبات
اكبر على العرب كان تحرك الدول الخليجيه
اللافت بطرد السفراء السوريين واستدعاء
سفرائها من دمشق خطوه جريئه وفاعله لكن كف
اذى نظام الاسد عن شعبه يستدعي من العرب
جميعا مواقف لا تكون اقل حزما او حسما فاي
خيارات وبدائل امام العرب بعد عثره مجلس
الامن
الاخيره المطلوب اجراءات من النوع الذي
يصفه نبيل العربي بواضح المعالم والذي
يفضي لوقف نزيف الدم السوري والتحرك في
جميع الاتجاهات لبلوغ ذلك مسؤول
الدبلوماسيه السعوديه الامير سعود الفيصل
يريد امرا مشابها قرارات حاسمه وعدم
التهاون مع النظام السوري واعاده النظر في
المبادره
العربيه سريعا جاءت الترج
فاجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه كرس
القطيعه الدبلوماسيه مع نظام الاسد وزاد
من عزلته كما اوصى الوزراء العرب بفتح
قنوات اتصال مع المعارضه السوريه ودعمها
ماديا وسياسيا ومع اهميه ذلك كله فان
اللافته دعوه مجلس الامن الى تشكيل قوه
حفظ سلام عربيه امميه مشتركه خاصه بسوريا
يمكن من الان توقع رده فعل النظام في دمشق
على قرارات كهذه ليست من النوع المداهن او
المهادن وليس صعبا معرفه رايه في مجموعه
اصدقاء سوريا التي رحبت دول عربيه بدعوه
تونس لاستضافه مؤتمر دولي لها نهايه الشهر
الجاري مؤتمر قد يشكل سانحه لتبلور رؤيه
دوليه واضحه عن كيفيه مساعده الشعب السوري
يستنتج البعض ان النظام الرسمي العربي اخذ
يتعامل مع الوضع في سوريا بكل جديه
بانتظار تنفيذ
مقرراته ومع ذلك ستجد من الناشطين
السوريين من يرى ان الجامعه العربيه لم
تحقق سوى الحد الادنى مما كان مرجوا منها
يقولون ذلك واعينهم على شعب لا يزال يدفع
وحده من دمه ثمن توقه لدوله الديمقراطيه
وللحريه وعلى نظام يسفك دم شعبه ذاك لا
يزال طليق يد مع ابوك مع ابوك ولمناقشة
ك سيده بسمه قضماني ما اتخذ اليوم من
قرارات واعتبر خطوه يعني كبيره للامام هل
هي كذلك بالنسبه لكم وانتم ما فاتم يعني
ترددون
بان يعني الخطوات العربيه
بطيئه لا نرى نرى بلا شك انه هناك خطوه
مشجعه جدا من قبل الجامعه العربيه وما طرح
يلوح بان هناك اراده حقيقيه في الوصول الى
اجراءات عمليه على
الارض الخطابات التي سمعناها
من وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير سعود
الفيصل ومن الشيخ حمد ومن السيد الكتور
نبيل العربي امين جامعه الدول العربيه
اعتقد كل هذه الخطابات تدل على ان هناك
اراده حقيق
في انقاذ الشعب اليوم الاصرار وكان
اصرارنا كمجلس وطني سوري ان تصل منظمات
الاغاثه الدوليه الى الاراضي السوريه ان
الاغاثه اصبحت هي الاولويه الاولى ما
يعاني منه الشعب ك لم يعد محتمل باي معيار
من المعايير واعتقد ان الجامعه اليوم
بقرارها خرجت
بلهجه وبقرارات وبنود هذا القرار تشير الى
ان هناك فعلا رغبه فيض
قدما بخطوات عمليه على الارض كل البنود
اللي قراناها منها
فكره قوى حفظ السلام على الارض او فكره ان
اللجوء الى دول المجلس الامن لتتحمل
مسؤولياتها اذا كان النظام مازال رافضا
لايصال المعونات للشعب ولوقف العنف طبعا
قبل ان تصل هذه المعونات المطلوب اليوم ان
يتوقف تتوقف العمليات العسكريه وير ع
الحصار عن المدن السوريه كل هذه المطالب
التي نعلم الان ان النظام لن يتعامل معها
كما لم يتعامل معها حتى الان هذه المطالب
وضعت ولكن وضعت اجراءات عمليه في حال
سيرفض النظام ونعلم مع الاسف انه رفض ذلك
حتى منذ دقائق اوصل رده على هذه القرارات
برفضه القرار جمله
وتفصيلا دكتور خالد الدخيل التعويل مره
اخرى على الامم المتحده بعد فشل
المحاوله السابقه رغم انها كانت اقل وطاه
على النظام السوري من من من مما اتخذ من
قرارات اليوم هل لهذه العوده ما
يبررها هو الحقيقه ما في خيار الان
حاليا يعني نظرا لطبيعه الوضع العربي
وطبيعه
ما يشبه الانقسام داخل الجامعه العربيه
نحن سمعنا عن تحفظ
الجزائر طبعا يعني التحفظ اللبناني متوقع
الموقف العراقي كان
مشجع
لكن لابد الحقيقه من خطوتين يعني انا
اتصور من اجل ان يتهيا الوضع لاتخاذ قرار
في الامم
المتحده اول هذه
الخطوات هو ان يتم الاتفاق حقيقه على رفع
الغطاء العربي كاملا عن النظام
السوري ثانيا لابد من ان تعمل الدول
العربيه مع الصين اولا ثم مع روسيا موقف
الصين كان في الامم المتحده لافت جدا لانه
عندما انعقد مجلس الامن الجلسه الجلسه
الجلسه الاخيره وحصل فيها الفيتو الصيني
والروسي ما كان هناك حاجه حقيقه للفيتو
الصيني القرار كان سي سقط بالفيتو الروسي
كان بامكان الصين على الاقل ان تمتنع عن
التصويت لكن الصين استغلت الموقف لتوجيه
رساله للولايات
المتحده يبدو ان الصين قلقه من ما يسم
دكتور دخيل سنتطرق الى الموقفين الروسي
والصيني لاحقا
ولكن يعني ربما كان علي
اضافه كلمه التعويل على العوده الى الامم
الم المتحده من اجل نتيجه افضل من النتيجه
السابقه هل لهذا التعويل ما ما
يبرره انا اخشى حقيقه انه لجوء الجامعه
العربيه بهذا الوضع وفي هذه الحاله الى
مجلس الامن يعني قد يعبر عن ضعف الموقف
العربي انا اتصور انه مشكله الوضع في
سوريا حاليا هو الانقسام العربي وضعف
الموقف العربي وعدم قدره العالم العربي
على اتخاذ
المبادره وخلق وقائع على الارض داخل
العالم العربي هل العالم العربي فقط من من
ثبت عجزه دكتور دخيل انا اعتقد ان العالم
العربي هو يعني هو الان نقطه الضعف الى
جانب طبعا يعني الى جانب المعارضه لكن انا
اتصور انه نقطه الضعف الرئيسيه هي في
العالم العربي شوف النظام السوري لن
يستجيب لاي من هذه القرارات التي اتخ هذا
يعني مجلس الجامعه العربيه النظام السوري
م مصمم على انه يقضي على الثوره وان يقضي
على الاحتجاجات داخل سوريا باي ثمن كان
ولا بد من التعامل مع الوضع في سوريا
انطلاقا من هذه النقطه يعني يعني حكايه
مراقبين يعني اما ان النظام السوري لن
يقبلها وحتى لو قبلها سيتعامل معها بنفس
الطريقه وسيصر على شروط بنفس الطريقه التي
وضع
مع مجموعه المراقبين العرب الاولى التي تم
حلها في يعني في الاجتماع الاخير لابد
الحقيقه من حسم عربي ولا بد يعني اذا
اقتضى الامر طيب كيف انه مثلا بشكل واضح
دكتور دخيل قبل ان نعود مره اخرى الى
ضيفتنا السيده بسمه قضماني ما الذي يمكن
ان يعني يتخذه العرب من قرارات اكثر مما
اتخذوا الى حد
الان لابد ان يتخذون مثلا موضوع توفير
الملاذات
الامنه لابد من التنسيق مع
تركيا لابد من رفع الغطاء العربي كامل
انقطع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع النظام
السوري وربما لا بد
من قرار اليوم دكتور
دخيل قطع العلاقات قطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع سوريا بشكل نهائي كما ي
يبدو اتخذ بشانه قرار اليوم لا هو كان في
يعني في يعني كان في شيء من التردد انه
عدم وقف التعاون
الدبلوماسي وقف جميع اشكال التعاون
الدبلوماسي مع النظام السوري هذه خطوه
صحيح
انها يعني واضح انها مؤشر انه الجامعه
تتجه الى قطع العلاقات كامله مع النظام
السوري لا بد من رفع الغطاء كاملا عن
النظام السوري
لاج الظام السوري الع عموما هذه
الخطوه سيده بسمه هل فهمتم هذه الاجراءات
على انها
قطع للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه بشكل تام مع
النظام
السوري لا شك انه عزل النظام اصبح واضحا
من قبل الدول العربيه التركيز على ضروره
عقوبات اقتصاديه وتطبيق هذه العقوبات لانه
تطبيقها دائما يبقى يبقى متاخرا وغير
مكتملا اعتقد انه الاصرار على ذلك ايضا
مؤشر مشجع جدا ما انتزعه اليوم الشعب
السوري من القرار الع من مجموعه الدول
العربيه هو يعني ليس ليس قليلا اعتقد اننا
نتوجه نحو الان اليه عمل تتضمن دعم من
مجموعه الدول المسانده للشعب السوري كنا
نتمنى ان يتم ذلك من خلال مجلس الامن انما
بسبب تعذر ذلك في مجلس الامن فالبديل الذي
طرح وهو مجموعه الدول المسانده مجموعه
اصدقاء سوريا هذه المجموعه ربما تكون
قادره الان بارادتها السياس السياسيه
وبقدراتها ان ان تجتمع
وتقرر اليات واجراءات عمليه على الارض نحن
نطالب ب اغاثه الشعب و باسعاف الشعب اليوم
هذه المجموعه اعتقد انها قادره على ان
تقوم بذلك وهذا المطلب الذي اصبحنا لدينا
الامل ان يصل تصل المنظمات الاغاثه ويكون
هناك اجراءات عمليه على الارض الكتور دخيل
تحدث عن ممرات امنه وملاذ امن هذا لم يقرر
في هذه في هذا اللقاء للجامعه العربيه
الدول العربيه وحدها لا تستطيع ق قال انه
يجب التنسيق في هذا الخصوص مع مع ولكن قبل
ان نذهب الى فاصل سيده بسمه فقط في خصوص
قطع العلاقات يعني راينا انه لا يزال هناك
من يتحفظ على ذلك هل تعتقدين انه في
المرحله القريبه المقبله سنرى اقفال شامل
وعام للسفارات السوريه في مختلف العواصم
العربيه يعني التوجه هو نحو ذلك انا اعتقد
والمساله لمساله وقت الدول المتحفظه عليها
ان تثبت الان لماذا تتحفظ هل ترى انه هناك
اي امل ان يتعاون النظام في اي شيء لنذهب
الى مجلس الامن مره اخرى ونطلب من روسيا
والصين ان تصوت لقرار في مجلس الامن هذا
ليس مرفوضا لكن اذا كانت الدول ما زالت
تعتقد ان هذا النظام ربما يتعاون فهو رفض
مره اخرى دقائق بعد اتخاذ القرار هذا رفض
كل المبادره هذه فنحن
نتحدث عن نظام اصبح عازل نفسه هو بنفسه
حتى والدول التي تساند ما زالت او تتردد
في في في قرارها اعتقد ان عليها اليوم ان
تقول لنا لماذا وما هو البديل حقيقه اذا
القرارات التي اتخذت اليوم في الجامعه
العربيه لا تزال على الورق لكن كيف يمكن
تجاوز العقبه الروسيه الصينيه اذا ما عرضت
الخطه على مجلس الامن ناقش ذلك بعد فاصل
قصير ارجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الى
حلقتنا التي تناقش الرهانات العربيه
الجديده بشان سوريا في ضوء مقررات اجتماع
القاهره
دكتور خالد الدخيل في في الرياض تطرقت انت
منذ البدايه الى الموقف الروسي تحديدا ومن
ثم الموقف الصيني فيما يتعلق بالموقف
الروسي يعني لم يشهد ولم يطرا عليه اي نوع
من المرونه او او التغيير منذ الفيتو
السابق ما الذي يمكن ان ينتظره العرب اذا
ما عادوا مره اخرى الى مجلس الامن للحصول
على موافقه بارسال قوات تضم الى قوات عرب
يه لتصبح امميه
عربيه انا لا اتصور حقيقه في الوضع الحالي
القائم لا
يمكن يعني نظرا للموقف الروسي الموقف
الروسي يبدو لي نهائي في هذا الموضوع على
الاقل حتى
الان لكن مجلس الامن اذا كان في امكانيه
انه يتخذ
خطوه على طريقه التي طرحها مجلس الجامعه
اليوم لا لا بد ان يكون هناك موقف عربي
موحد واضح حول هذه القضيه وبخطوات عمليه
واضحه هذه
واحده اذا كان الموقف الروسي لن يتغير
وانا الحقيقه استغرب الى الان انه كيف ان
الدول العربيه وخاصه دول الخليج ان ما
استطاعت انها تتفاهم مع الروس على حل وسط
لهذه القضيه على
الاقل في هذه الحاله تعتقد انه لم يبدل اي
جد عربي باتجاه باتجاه لا روسيا ولا الصين
انا اعتقد انه يعني حتى الان اما انه لم
يكن هناك جهود كافيه او انها جهود لم تؤتي
ثمارها الى الان خاصه مع الروس الصينيين
يعني اقرب انه يعني الصين ممكن تحييدها
ممكن يعني ممكن التفاهم مع الصين على عدم
يعني على امتناع عن التصويت روسيا تبدو
اصعب لان روسيا تخشى بشكل كبير جدا
من سقوط النظام السوري لانه هذا قد يشجع
ايضا انتقال الربيع الى ايران في فتره
الانتخابات القادمه وهي تخشى انه تنتشر
هذه الثورات في الجمهوريات جمهوريات
الاتحاد السوفيتي وبالتالي سيكون الربيع
على حدود روسيا وهذا مخيف طبعا يعني كما
تع الطاقم الحاكم الان في روسيا وخاصه
بوتين هو ينتمي الى مرح مله الحرب البارده
وهو لا يتفق مع كل ويخشى مع كل هذه
التحركات ولذلك انا اعتقد انه يجب ان يكون
التركيز في هذه المرحله على ما يسمى
بمجموعه اصدقاء سوريا وهو وهي وهي
المجموعه التي سوف تجتمع في يعني في تونس
في نهايه هذا الشهر معه نهايه هذا الشهر
اي يعني حتى الان يعني ايضا فتره طويله
لكن المعول الرئيسي في هذا الموضوع هو
الموقف العربي وحده الموقف العربي و اتخاذ
خطوات عمليه ارسال فرق الاغاثه كما قالت
السيده قضماني
وارسال
مراقبين لكن لابد من التفكير بشكل جاد
بفتح الملاذات الامنه في تركيا وفي الاردن
وتوفير الغطاء والحمايه التي يحتاجها
الاردن لاتخاذ هذه الخطوه والتفاهم او
التنسيق مع الاتراك حول هذه القضيه طيب اي
دكتور الموقف العربي لا يستطيع مجلس الامن
ان يتحرك وايضا يبدو انه بدون الموقف
الروسي والصيني ايضا العالم كله لا يمكن
ان يتحرك دكتوره
بسمه يعني خلاف المراحل الاولى التي كان
فيها ربما اخذ وعطاء مع روسيا كانت هناك
زيارات كثيره لوفود من المعارضه يبدو انها
انقطعت الان اذا سد اغلق الباب الروسي هل
يمكن التعويل على نوع من من الليونه او
التحييد للموقف الصيني كما اشار الى ذلك
الدكتور خالد
الدخيل خاصه مع زياره الوفد الصيني
للمنطقه
لشرح ابعاد واسباب الموقف
الصيني نعم اعتقد انه هناك يعني حرج عند
الصين بشكل خاص واراده رغبه في التواصل مع
المجلس الوطني و
فهم ما هي الامكانيات التشاور معها لانه
انقطاع الاتصال سيضر في
مصالح الصين اليوم خاصه وان الدول العربيه
تجمع على عزل النظام بقرارها اليوم اعتقد
انه ما نراه من طرف روسيا هو انها اخذت
موقف هي تعلم انه مكلف جدا لها في
المستقبل القريب والبعيد اذا استمرت بهذا
الموقف انا لا ادري اذا كان هناك امكانيه
لتغيير هذا الموقف الروسي فهو متشنج جدا
ولم يتعاطى مع الواقع السوري وما زال يدعي
ان هناك دعم للنظام في الداخل نحن نعلم ان
كل فئات المجتمع السوري اليوم اما انقلبت
ضد للنظام علنا او انها انقلبت وهي صامته
وبعضها خائف من ال مما ياتي بعد النظام
ولكنه يايئس من هذا النظام اعتقد انه
القرارات العربيه اليوم هي مشجعه لفئات
المجتمع الصامته ان تخرج وتعلن انها تنقلب
على هذا النظام هذا سيشجع من يضحي اليوم
في حمص وفي ادلب وفي مناطق سوريه كلها
شعبنا ضحى بما فيه الكفايه وعلى باقي فئات
المجتمع ان تنضم الان الى هذه الثوره وت
وتثق بان بان المستقبل سنبني كلنا كمجتمع
واحد وعلى روسيا ان تنظر الى ذلك اليوم
فئات المجتمع هي تتعاون هناك تضامن كبير
على الارض واذا كانت روسيا ترى هذا الواقع
عليها ان تطوي هذه الصفحه
التاريخ المظلم في تاريخنا تطويه معنا مع
الشعب السوري ولا تقف مع هذا النظام
الدكتور
الدخيل يعني بتشكيل قوات عربيه امميه ولو
على مستوى الفكره والاقتراح هل تدشن
الجامعه
العربيه مرحله
جديده اسم التدخل الاجنبي بشكل ما بعدما
كانت يعني تؤكد بانه لا مجال لذلك في في
كل ايا كانت يعني الاوضاع في
سوريا شوفي قبل ما اتكلم عن يعني عن فكره
التدخل الاجنبي انا يعني انا اتصور انه
ايضا العامل السوري او يعني العامل السوري
الداخلي مهم جدا زخم الثوره انا اعرف انه
هناك تضحيات كبيره حقيقه قدمها الشعب
السوري في هذه الثوره وهي م وهي احدى
مفاجات الربيع العربي ام شجاعه الشعب
السوري لم يكن احد يتوقعها ان تكون على
هذه الدرجه من
التضحيات لكن للاسف انه هذا الشعب هو امام
نظام شرس
وقاسي ويتفع بشعارات هو يعرف انها لا اساس
لها من الواقع ولذلك الزخم الثوري داخل
سوريا في حلب وفي دمشق وفي بقيه المدن
التي لم تشارك الى الان سوف يساعد الموقف
العربي وسوف يساعد الموقف الدولي وسوف
يضعف من الموقف الروسي ايضا طيب طيب
بالنسبه للتدخل
الاجنبي انا اعتقد انه الطريق الذي يسير
فيه النظام حاليا ا سوف يفجر الوضع في
سوريا وسوف يؤثر على دول الجوار بما في
ذلك تركيا والعراق ولبنان وبالتالي سوف
يفرض التدخل يج بشكل يجعل التدخل الاجنبي
ربما مقبول لمن كان يرفض اعتقد انه هذه
فكرتك واعتذر ان يستبق لان الوقت لم يبقى
منه الكثير بسمه قضماني اخيرا يعني اليوم
العرب اليوم يتحدثون عن فتح قنوات اتصال
جديده مع المعارضه وضروره الاعتراف
بالمجلس الوطني لا بل المجلس الوطني هو
الذي يطلب الاعتراف به اذا افترضنا انه
الان تنزع الشرعيه وبشكل واضح ونهائي عن
النظام الا يفترض ان يخلق كيان اخر تمنح
لوش الشرعيه وهذا الكيان هو انتم المجلس
الوطني المجلس الوطن الوطني عمل بكل صدق
وبكل امكانياته على توحيد صفوف المعارضه
اعتقد اننا وصلنا الى عبرنا خطوات كبيره
في هذا الاتجاه في المراحل الاخيره في
الايام الاخيره والاسابيع الاخيره وانه
هذا المجلس اصبح حقيقه هو الاطار الوطني
وليس حزبا وليس تيارا واحدا وانما المظ لا
ز ينظر
الاعراف شكرا جزيلا واعتذر لمقاطعته الوقت
انتهى بسمه قضماني
المتحدثه باسم المجلس الوطني السوري كنت
معنا من القاهره واشكر من الرياض
الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي الدكتور خالد
ال الخيل نهايه هذه الحلقه تحيه لكم اينما
كنتم